all right all right let's keep going
things don't look sorry lunch season
week two give me the trivia question
please way to ignore my comment good job
by you what asd wes qb had the most pass
attempts of any qb last week
i you know it can't be a starter right
i'm thinking chase daniel but i i was
watching that game i don't think he
played a lot or let me just throw a dart
and say chad henny oh negative ghost
rider sorry nathan peterman played the
whole game as the only guy for the
raiders oh god right the whole game the
whole game yes wow
hey one thing i i don't know i'm just
going to say this before we start the
draft i said this on my podcast
yesterday i we know mariota was on the
trade block in the off season he
took a pay cut
i got every indication watching that
game on film that
like when we know from hard knocks
everything gruden has a love affair with
nathan peterman to a degree
i just wonder if mariota will be maybe
one of those guys on the trade block at
the end of training camp like if i'm the
baltimore ravens i'm calling the raiders
right now going we need a backup
quarterback because mcsorley gets hurt
every time he steps on the field and
we'll be out of the super bowl hunt if
we have to rely on our backup that would
they're the cowboys or the cowboys
exactly so that just jumps out to me
mariota of course fits the ravens way
they play a little bit more that's why i
said that but yes i believe mariota got
a no trade clause when he agreed to take
that dramatic pay cut but if hey
if if you're wanted somewhere yeah and
you see a potential path to the field
then you take it that's right and gruden
was all in with peterman in the 20 yes
17 draft i think the year of mahomes and
watson gruden was all over of course he
was also once all in with johnny manziel
so that that that should tell you a lot
about 19 and 29 in three years with the
raiders the fact that he was all over
nathan peterman and johnny manziel all
right you get the first pick things to
look for in week two of the preseason
man i hate to be like this obvious right
but but i mean the the the three rookie
qb's that that's what i'm no no no no
you can't do all three okay you gotta
give me one we gotta grab three rounds
of the draft come on
okay fine all right i'll go to
trey lance
and that the trey lance with their match
up this weekend i don't even forget who
they're playing here because i got to
look at they are chargers right charges
i got it i just want to continue to see
like we talked about earlier there is
some flash and some wow and then there's
also some what and you miss that and
what huh so i want to see if we improve
any of that i want to see if shanahan
continues to put him in positions for
all of us to go wow to open up the door
to go hey trey you could still start
week one we're gonna you know get all
the clamoring going and all that i think
that's the one that jumps out most to me
7 30 p.m eastern sunday night televised
nationally on nfl network 49ers at the
chargers i'm going tonight
the first game one of the first games of
week two of the preseason the
philadelphia eagles the only game
tonight 7 30 p.m eastern nfl network
patriots at the eagles cam newton
can cam show us enough
to hold off mac jones the clock is
already ticking jones looks like he runs
the offense more smoothly more
decisively more efficiently than cam
what will we see from cam that may make
us think he can he can stave this off
because i know week one of the regular
season is the focal point but for the
patriots week four of the regular
season's got to be the key that's when
tom brady comes back to town you want
your best quarterback on the field you
want to know who it is by then yeah no
doubt about it yeah it'll be interesting
to watch too you're right every sense
you get out of there is like it seemed
like hey it was going to be cam but mack
is doing so good that it seems like even
though new england doesn't love rookies
playing that there might be that chance
there okay here's another one that i'm
kind of interested to see just because
of some of the things you read and what
you hear at a camp right now i know you
got one catch last week but jamar chase
i'm gonna be watching him a little bit
closely this week you know there hasn't
been raving reviews about him in
training camp to this point i know we
talked about it on a podcast i think
like a week or two ago yeah he missed
football last year i don't care what you
say you're a wide receiver you're not in
football shape i don't care who you
train with so i mean he's the fifth pick
of the draft they they passed up penny
sewell for him you know i am i'm gonna
i'm gonna definitely give that a close
look this week to see if jamar chase
really looks the part and can he be that
bona fide number one guy for the bangos
right here in year one
that's part of a great friday night
split screen nfl network eight o'clock
eastern bengals at washington also at
that same time 8 p.m eastern espn at
chiefs at cardinals so two games
nationally televised same time that
doesn't happen very often in the nfl so
uh fun to watch both of those games at
once next one for me i'm going monday
night espn jaguars at saints the saints
quarterback battle taysom hill jameis
winston who looks better where will the
clues be who gets more reps will they
maybe have
take some hell out on the field when
jameis winston is playing quarterback
who knows but that's one that i think is
going to go all the way down to the wire
and it could go either way and we're
going to get i think plenty of
additional information on monday night
even though we're still a couple of
weeks away from knowing who it's going
to be week one when they play the
packers yeah that's a good one for sure
i mean that's that's probably the
most like what what i want to say equal
quarterback battle we got in the nfl
right now where we're really like
not sure where that's gonna go so that
will be interesting uh let's see my last
pick
you know i'm gonna go to
uh i'm gonna go to se i'm taking sam
darnold i am i mean hey it's a new team
it's a new look he's got some support
around him i want to see what sam
darnold looks like in this offense with
some of these guys they got in carolina
that should be pretty cool they got the
raven saturday night i just i'm
interested to see his look the offense
around him i think carolina is one of
those teams to kind of watch out for
this year not saying they're going to
make a playoffs but they got a roster
that i look at and i go i think they can
be a pain in the butt for a lot of teams
in the nfl
can the panthers end
the 18-game pre-season winning streak
of the baltimore ravens last one for me
saturday night eight o'clock
vikings hosting the colts first look at
kirk cousins the quarterback position
has been muddled to say the least in
minnesota because of the covet issues
how will kirk run this offense now that
clint kubiak is in charge how much will
we see from him and and just that whole
just that i just think there's got to be
some frustration organizationally about
kirk and the vaccine issue i want to see
how he does first time on the field with
this potential or actual distraction
that's going on as mike zimmer makes his
thoughts known about getting everyone
vaccinated and and available each and
every week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports